[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Приазов'я,
Бердянськ]
[собаці] Лежати, лежати. Хороший.
Відпочивають до 70 людей з дітьми.
Це дуже зручний формат.
[Олександр Величко
Власник пансіонату «Будиночок біля моря»]
По-перше, дорослі з дітьми завжди
себе дуже добре поводять.
У мене працює бар-кухня, шестеро людей.
Три охоронці, адміністратор,
вчитель з фізкультури, вихователь,
аніматор, три покоївки.
Я і сам – частина персоналу,
я ж катаю людей на кораблику.
Що ближче до лінії фронту, то більше патріотизму.
Бердянську пощастило.
Він простояв на межі,
і йому це допомогло усвідомити,
як близько цей жах.
Просто люди, які приїхали,
розповідали про погроми,
про цю орду, що вирвалася,
цих мародерів.
Це різко змінило настрій міста.
Бердянськ раптом зрозумів,
що Україна величезна, люди чудові.
І про Москву вже не згадують,
про Росію не згадують...
Реально велика проблема Бердянська як міста –
це низький рівень доходів.
Їде молодь,
відповідно психотип міста визначається
старими людьми.
Дуже багато пенсіонерів, зі 120,
номінально, тисяч жителів, 35 тисяч – пенсіонери.
Бердянськ реально є перлиною,
тепер, азовського узбережжя. І був, і буде.
Просто цю перлину можна відмити.
Але для цього сюди повинні
приходити великі гроші.
Торік спустив «Бродягу» [волоцюгу] на воду пізно.
Спускаю, катаю відпочивальників.
І ніколи не думав, що мені буде так подобатися.
Я за освітою – програміст. А ось ця іграшка...
Тобто це не комерційний проєкт.
У Бердянську народився,
вступив до інституту, працював...
Загалом, абсолютно міським був.
Почав їздити на риболовлю весною.
Рік, другий, потім купив човен, збудував готель.
І водночас бізнес все одно лишався у Харкові.
В якийсь момент Харків став пригнічувати.
Я зрозумів, що мені простіше
переїхати до Бердянська
і деколи їздити до Харкова.
Море не дозволяє стерти це місто.
Тут живуть люди цілковито дивовижні.
Вони завжди раді гостям.
Але водночас вони не підлещуються до них.
До останнього часу
так само приймали
гостей з Росії.
У мене 9 років відпочивала
«баба Свєта» з Москви.
І коли вона мені в березні зателефонувала:
«Саня, ти що? Що ви там творите? Крим – наш!»
Тобто в мене був шок.
Тоді я вперше зіштовхнувся
з таким «махровим кримнашем».
От поведінка росіян у Бердянську була от ця...
Комплекс «старшого брата»,
які приїжджали і казали:
«Українці в Бердянську – такі милі».
В 2014 році було, звичайно, трошки не до моря.
Я в серпні почав помічати,
що якась дуже чиста вода.
В 2015 це вже було добре помітно,
я вже тоді почув,
що море стає солонішим.
У минулому році 13 проміле, проти норми у 10.
Цьогоріч — під 15 проміле.
Причина солоності...
Це модель, що вже виказана неофіційно.
У Сиваш зливається робочий до перешийка
Дніпровсько-Кримський канал.
Відповідно, підіймається рівень Сиваша
і йде приток.
Але те, що іхтіологія змінилася,
біохімія – видно по воді.
Торік була дуже жорстка заборона
на виловлювання промислове.
Я вперше бачив катери тут, бригади...
Може, морю й краще буде.
Час, час...
Це стосується до всього.
Як до росту поголів'я пелінгасу,
так і до реформ в Україні.
[сміється]
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Дмитро Бартош, Дмитро Охріменко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
Fudo Kazuki, Tik Tu]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]